I above the Black Sea this was the
moment of contact a Russian jet dumps
fuel as it approaches an unmanned U.S
surveillance drone the Pentagon says
this was an effort to take it down
having filled once there is another
attempt
this time the footage from the onboard
camera cuts out the Americans say
because the Russian aircraft connected
with the propeller ultimately the
Russian military and the Russian
government is responsible for its own
behavior and when that behavior is
unsafe and unprofessional we're going to
call it out as we've done in this case
the Russians dispute the U.S version of
events surrounding its MQ-9 Reaper drone
stating the Russian aircraft made no
contact with the Drone and that it came
down after attempting a sharp maneuver
the tale of the tape suggests
differently after one fly past the Drone
propeller appears intact and operational
following another one of the blades is
bent dumping fuel around it seems to be
an effort to stop the engine of the
Drone working then they were trying to
come up from behind and then use their
aerodynamics to push the fuel into the
engine and then frankly it was Mercury
incompetence that led to them getting a
bit too close and actually hitting the
Drone itself
this Reaper drone incident is the first
military contact between the U.S and
Russia since the Ukraine war started the
risk is that Russia deliberately does it
again that they want to escaritas to
look like a U.S Russia conflict so they
may try to do more things that would
draw a U.S response
U.S officials say they're unsure if this
Collision was deliberate or accidental
but insist they'll continue to fly
drones in international airspace therein
lies a test of Russian intentions
James Matthews Sky News Washington